un lanzamiento supervisado por kim
jong-un corea del norte lanzó su nuevo
misil intercontinental
fue a watson 17 el primero desde 2017
que además rompe la moratoria que el
gobierno norcoreano se autoimpuso en
2018 para tratar de lograr una calma
diplomática ante los señalamientos de
eeuu lanzado desde el aeropuerto
internacional de pyongyang el misil
ascendió a una altura máxima de 6 mil
248 kilómetros voló mil 90 kilómetros
durante 40 52 segundos y aterrizó con
precisión en el lugar planeado en aguas
de alta mar del mar del este de corea
eeuu y varios aliados solicitaron una
reunión urgente el consejo de seguridad
de la onu y tokio denunció que pyongyang
no notificó a las autoridades de tráfico
marítimo y aéreo extractos de uva no son
de corea del norte ha lanzado
frecuentemente misiles balísticos este
año incluyendo misiles
intercontinentales esta serie de hechos
por parte de corea del norte amenaza a
la paz y la seguridad de japón de la
región y de la comunidad internacional
eso no puede ser aceptado el lanzamiento
de hoy viola las resoluciones del
consejo de seguridad
el artefacto cayó en el mar de japón
cerca de la costa de hokkaido en el
norte del archipiélago lo que lo
convierte en el proyectil norcoreano que
ha caído más cerca de las costas niponas